here's televised mental institution
MSNBC with my favorite racist host Joy
Reid we talk about this all the time
democracy on the ballot it's not just a
slogan you know I mean we're talking
about women literally losing agency over
themselves Donald Trump has said you
know where he's going to challenge the
election already in advance he says he's
going to do it Philly
right I mean it's not even being hidden
at this point it's just fascism in the
open I mean I'm not calling I'm not
going to say that you know the GOP or
Nazis at this point or whatever but it
certainly sounds very familiar to what
happened in Germany which is a bunch of
citizens today Adolf Hitler gets a third
of the vote nobody thought it could
happen there they kind of went along
because they said he was going to solve
the economy and fix inflation yeah
that's right those sorts of things
absolute fear-mongering nonsense and
even the Chiron did you see the Chiron
at the end anti-Semitism On The Rise
well first off the hate crimes against
Jews are just it's just it's always
there Jews are always the number one
it's always number one uh the segment
obviously was about what Kanye's been
saying I have no defense of Kanye he
should not be defended uh but do you
think they ever do the anti-semitisms On
The Rise story uh when they're talking
about all of the black people who were
beaten the Orthodox Jews in Brooklyn or
how about Ilan Omar do they ever bring
her on they actually brought I mean this
was an incredible video from last week
they brought ilhan Omar to talk about
the rise of anti-Semitism I mean it's
just these people are you gotta they
should be studied they need to be
studied I'm not going to say it's like
Hitler but it is like Hitler it's not
like Nazi Germany but Nazis fascists and
now they're so concerned with what you
do with your body it's wild the same
people who want to still inject you with
all this stuff